so I guess the New York Post did a
article about me being drunk on Sex in
the City you remember that um yeah it
was on page six you called me so then
Norton texted me and goes are you okay
buddy I read that article I just want to
see if you're okay yeah and I'm like oh
we're friends and he's he loves me and
what a great guy what a sweet you know
God he like guys like that always like
text me when things are going wrong or
you know what I mean but yeah I mean
they're they're intimidating by anything
else no oh you're just genuinely genuine
it was genuinely are you okay I'm here
for you you know I talked to uh um when
Ari the Kobe thing happened oh my God I
remember Ari being like yeah all the New
York guys were like
honest and upfront like but like didn't
abandon me like he said that he was like
all you guys were like that joke sucked
but we love you yeah you know and it was
like he said like you know I'm not gonna
name names but he said people on the
west coast [__] we're like you lose
my number really this is what I want to
say now if you just hit something in me
and I'm gonna get in there
I think you're right
I think that some of the people on the
some people in the west right are
cowards yeah and they're scared yeah and
they're a little too woke for me yeah
right what they care about the Optics
they care of the Optics they're like I
can't be associated with friendships
over friendship with the New York guys
are in deep well it's we I truly think
that there's a thing of like there's an
honesty to the relationships there where
you're like no you just where you're
like should I move I I I think the thing
I do like about New York is that like
they'll tell you to your face if a joke
sucks don't do that joke and I feel like
in L.A there's not a lot of that well
the audience does that too yeah yeah
yeah yeah but I think um I think that
that's the one thing I like about New
York is that I know that no matter where
I go in the business I have a crew of
friends that will treat me the same yeah
and I think in La what happens is people
treat you accordingly like if like if
you're up people are like oh my God I
love seeing you and if you're down and
you do something [__] up they're like
I I just I can't right now yeah I don't
know
you're absolutely correct yeah you hit
it on the button dude because I've had
friends that have gone through all that
[__] and just immediately you reach out
and you're like all right dude this is
this sucks because you know how many
voices are coming at them being like you
[__] suck you're terrible and if you
just reach out and go like all right
this is this is brutal but I then make
fun of it I think theoretically but I
want to say this though I think that
people in New York Comics that go to New
York want to be real Comics right I
think that stand up I think they want to
focus primarily right and when they come
to La they have other dreams they want
listen man the thing is you can I can
knock La all I want the fact is La
Comics are better performers they're
better performers they tell jokes better
that's all I want to hear yeah but they
are they're on stage like UCLA guys
perform and you're like [__] I wish I
was that Unchained I wish I was that
unburdened to be like act out my jokes
like that yeah yeah but I also think New
York Comics are more like stand-up is
more important yeah I see like just like
the actual stand up is important writing
jokes and like yeah because when I was
like the seller the last time I played
the seller you know the Piano guy that's
there yeah yeah I was doing way too much
yeah
oh
do I score this yeah yeah and he looked
at me like like hey yeah no it's not
working my favorite thing about this
stuff yeah my favorite thing about the
seller and this is I think this is this
this is in La too this is everybody my
favorite thing at a comedy club is
making sure the staff is laughing ah
because if the staff is laughing you're
like you guys see all this horseshit
yeah so if they're not laughing you're
like is that joke suck yeah
yeah can I ask you something I did in
Hawaii that I haven't never brought this
up and I feel so ashamed about my
behavior and I want to see if you think
was I there for this you weren't there
no oh thank God and I feel like you
already felt preemptive embarrassment
yeah
and I didn't check him no you didn't
check no if you were the